you
we have to use the microphones this is
being recorded and
and uh
telecast out there
so
um
thank you audience for all being here
um we may be calling on you at certain
points where we need some help or advice
our
other other discussions
um
this is
the ways and means committee we're not
the policy committee although we we've
broadened our admission out a little bit
because of uh the banking provision
that we need to discuss we did add one
member of the full committee
who who's
from from from
commerce
and then we have three members of
finance none can make it because they're
all tied up upstairs right now they'll
be here on friday when we have our full
work session
so
um the thing though
traditionally we look at revenues from a
tax standpoint
this case it's a net
so there are a lot of issues in the bill
that will
impact
uh the net revenue
so so
so our discussions may be broadened that
way because
um
we may say well if we do things this way
the revenues the net revenue is going to
be this so if we do it this way
networking is going to be that
so so so bear with us we're going to
board this out a little bit to be able
to have those discussions
what i did for the committee is i came
up with bullet points
um i just went through the bill over the
weekend
and i i
i went in the order of the bill just
hopefully for convenience for everybody
and uh just to talk about things so i
have 14 points we want to make it
through
and then any other issues that any of
the members want to discuss
so
my first point was on page three where
we defined
uh manufacturers
on
lines four to seven
uh
and then i'm i'm thinking to myself
well
why why have manufacturers
i mean what manufacturers are we going
to attract
uh
if if
we're not going to be selling edibles
uh to the
to the consumers here
um
but i'm gonna take that and my second
point which is on line 19 to 22.
and you know which says that we're
limiting edibles to only those with a
medical card
so a lot of things came to mind with
that
so we're going to be stocking edibles
but then having to tell people with
non-medical cards
you can't buy that even though it's on
the shelf
that's a problem for the retailer the
staff
and then once customers find out there's
no edibles being sold in these in our
state stores
we're going to lose
customers they're going to say well
screwed we'll just keep on going to
and that that we're allowing people with
medical cards to buy edibles
at the state stores
my note to myself here was places state
atc's in direct competition with the
state-run stores
harmony
atc's and then
then we heard testimony
that edibles are between 15 and 50 of
the market
of our state stores okay
uh or of the market out there but over
the weekend
i said well what are we really talking
about and it's this is where we're going
to need some help here
uh when we talk about edibles edibles
and adjustables if you look at a little
chart here
i went to flowhub.com
can someone out there tell me a
flowhop.com is a reliable source of data
nobody knows okay
so it's
slash toolhub.com
dash industry dot dance statistics and
they claim and they had they had a chart
for last year 2020 for every month
what the
uh what
what was sold in the various uh
recreational stores
so edibles and inject ingestibles was 18
pre-rolls seven percent accessories one
percent number accessories can come from
other manufacturers not the ones we're
talking about here topicals which is the
ointments
one percent
flour
which is the traditional what everybody
thinks when they think of marijuana they
think of you know you buy loose
marijuana you roll your own
and then cartridges
26 now what's cartridge it's the it's
the vaping devices that instead of
having flavor in it that have marijuana
in it thc in it
or both all right you're my resident
expert i think i think nunes here is
going to be our expert
and then and then concentrates
which is 14 what are concentrates their
waxes and things like that
you take a little dab
you put it on the heat thing it goes
from solid to vapor
it's kind of like a hookah thing and
yeah and you you take it that way
so
i would imagine
that the manufacturers
would do the
edibles and adjustables they may even do
the pre-rolls because
i'm sure they'd have machines that make
them
consistent size and you know and all
that
accessories can come from any vendor i
would imagine
topical same thing
it would be something these are all
you're extracting the thc out of the
plant and putting it into something
the flower we know is the plant is the
flower you know the flower part of the
plant cartridges
that would come from
a manufacturer and so same thing with
concentrates
so
correct me but i don't i don't see all
of these things um well i think there
was some of them defined
so you know i i i inadvertently
group
all
when i saw manufacturing i was just
thinking of edibles and ingestibles at
but
manufacturers have a broader role they
would be making the pre-rolls topicals
cartridges and concentrates as well
uh i think we
we need to make sure in the bill
that that gets defined that way because
they're different kind of products
ingestible in ingest
whether it's uh whether it's a cookie or
brownie or
we have it in sodas i know i know states
have it in their sodas or some states
even have it in their beer
um
look
the five they find you the
the marijuana commission said don't do
that
um i i don't think we're planning on
doing that but
even though it's part of the liquor
commission this bill so
so
i i just think do we need a bit of a
discussion around that
do we need
um
do we do we need to amend this bill to
be more specific
as to what
and if we don't have
if we don't have
manufactured products
offered to the total public and not just
the meta people with the medical cards
then it's not much business because
according to this 33 is a flower
now again that's why i asked and uh mr
chair here
um i started by saying i got this from
flow hub
i don't know if you've ever heard of
that site
nope and i see it blank so that's a no
okay
we heard testimony that it was 15 to 50
of what sold
is
edibles
sure
thank you
i've heard of wide range
but the the consensus i kind of fall in
the middle on is that the manufactured
products
specifically edible products amount to
about a 30 market share but that market
share
is going up it's rising
and in some states it's even exceeded 50
so even if we're at 30 it's perceivable
in four or five years
that would go higher but part of
manufacturing also would include any
type of vape products
right which right here is about
again wide range but it's approximately
10 of the market share so the
manufacturing industry
i would say is pretty close to 50
already as is
i would believe and i i did notice in
the data that i looked over the weekend
i could see that it was growing as well
so
so this is where the problem is i mean
the problem is
so what are our state stores going to
sell if there's no no
no edibles
representative
you want to comment on that or
if there were no edible products
obviously the state store would not be
selling those the concern i had with not
having any edibles would be would the
manufacturing industry be able to
sustain itself without
without edibles i'm not sure that they
can
and
i asked
people in the industry i understand that
they're in the industry and would make a
profit
off of this but when you take away a
large portion of their market share
i think it basically might not survive
the intent of that language and i'll
take responsibility for
how it's written
was really that if someone
came to a state-run store
especially if they were from out of
state and they had a medical card they
could still purchase the edibles from
the store the idea was to not really put
a prejudice
negative impact on the medical industry
operating in new hampshire i understand
it's being perceived that way but the
intent was
the out-of-state consumer coming here
right okay representative want to ask a
question again or has a comment
well thank you uh mr chairman
representative abbas i know that um
we've talked a lot about about some
contention about medical being sold in
the stores
um do you have anything to say uh about
that about the rest of the medical
industry and maybe their feelings
there's people there in the room i'm
sure they're going to want to talk about
that as well but
well i'm i they'll do a better job
speaking about for themselves and their
feelings but my my thought was
if the medical industry
what what's sold in the state store does
not necessarily have to be a medical
grade edible product
i understand that for medical purposes
they can have a much higher thc level
treatments inside that that product
specifically we're just saying that if
someone's using edibles for example if
someone had lung cancer they obviously
can't
i assume that they won't be smoking at
least they shouldn't
i'm not a doctor but i can imagine
that's
that's the consensus
so
my concern my from my understanding the
medical cards
right now the medical industry there was
a law passed allowing them to accept
out-of-state medical cards but if that
policy hasn't been implemented yet
i don't know what the hold-up is on that
but i would support
i had no i don't see any reason why they
they shouldn't be allowed to accept an
odyssey medical card either
in respect to
working together
if
the medical industry if they have
cultivation sites already
if they were to grow
cultivate and sell their products to the
state whether it's a lower grade doesn't
have to be medical grade whatever their
branding is whatever their product that
they make
i don't see any reason why that wouldn't
they couldn't be
state it seems to me
that that would be a win-win for
everyone involved they already had
they're already operational they already
have regulations in place they have
rules in place some of the criticism is
that the rule making process for the
retail
could might not it might be difficult to
make the deadlines well
it sounds like the medical industry
would be able to
kind of start and start from day one so
i think we can work together but i think
it needs to be
a mutual agreeable relationship where
we're all working together
that's actually my point five that on
this my sheep is
can new hampshire a c atc's
atc's
apply for these licenses given their
special status in the state
what needs to be changed for this to
happen do we atc's
i can answer that question i know they
did
if this was a normal
run business
the the
when we had the marijuana commission
and the commission one recommendations
is that we were going to give them a
pathway and it was testimony to that
effect too
to
we said give the atcs a pathway to have
a second part of their stores to offer
recreational
so but that's not in the bill
um and i'm not quite sure
uh whether
whether this
you know whether given the way we we've
the laws were surrounding our a
tcs have to be modified in some way to
allow that to happen
and can i
is this directly on that that point
because lang had his questions
yeah okay you go first
part of his process i i'm trying not to
jump around we seem to be running
through this all this and not actually
having a good conversation on each each
of the 14 points
and i guess i want to go back to number
one and number two to have a good
conversation around one and two so we
can close that loop and finish the
conversation
but to the point we're specifically
talking about right now it was
uh was my inclination in our
conversations here hoping to get to the
point where we would allow
for the atcs either through a parallel
licensing
option to be able to sell to the state
if we carve that out so i think they're
already
a lack of a bit of phrase homegrown
cultivators right here in the state that
would have a natural product to allow
the state stores to be able to start
selling once they open because otherwise
we'll be waiting months for someone to
grow a product to be able to sell to the
state if we don't give them a path
so if you if you look at this there has
to be
unless we're looking at a year down the
road for to give cultivators time to
produce product
if we open a store the only place we're
gonna be able to get product right now
is from an atc cultivator it's currently
licensed and allow them to apply for a
cultivator and manufacturer license but
we would need to make changes to the
current law to allow them to do that but
it was my inclination to if we're going
down this road to
to make to request that as part of the
amendment we make that change to allow
cultivators atc cultivators and
manufacturers um to your point about
manufacturers um again i think it's
along the same line right so
this is kind of a forward-looking bill
right the idea is we don't know what
this is going to look like in five years
from now and so defining the term so we
understand what they are so people can
you know
alone privatization we have a definition
cannabis manufacturer is already in
statute it's only a matter of backing
out the state portion to now turn it
into a private portion
so
um again i i think that a lot of the
terms you're seeing here is a is
representative atmos chairman abbott did
a great job in looking forward to what
are the potential downfalls or changes
that are going to happen in this law and
how can i put the definitions we need to
keep this forward-looking bill
looking at the future and and what might
happen so when i look at things like why
have licensed manufacturers the reason
being is a we may have products we want
to license that that are allowed there
could be a change in a law that the
manufacturing license process would be
there and especially if we allow the atc
manufacturers to sell to the state
products hashish is probably one of the
ones i was thinking about it's a
concentrate that would be allowed by
this statute um uh
you know so again
i'd like to walk through the
your points you make really good points
in your in your document here but i
don't want to jump all over the place it
was related to
atc so that's fine that's fine thank you
and lastly i sort of remember the one
point i think what you know for me in
this whole conversation the operative
word is legalization
right the rest of it is all how we go
about it and we're talking about the how
right the question is do we agree on
legalization as a concept right and
that's a policy discussion that the
criminal justice committee has already
made so now we're just looking about how
we go about it so i just want to say one
thing before uh
so we have atc's we have three companies
with seven stores
and they're vertically integrated just
understand what we have right now and
they're vertically integrated so they do
the cultivating they do the
manufacturing and they do the uh the
retail
so that's the background that's what's
there
i'm sure they and if there's somebody
from any of those etcs that want to jump
in
that
i know well let's go first but we do
want to know from the atc's
if you're any of them representative
that uh
would help you out in terms of
and what we need to do to have that
yeah i wanted to go back a step um
and ask this question which is really a
question for the committee
and that is whether edibles having them
are not
for sale to all consumers and new
hampshire
is on the table
that question of
of having them having edibles in the
retail stores for all consumers
is that uh is that beyond the scope or
the reason i think it is in scope and
the reason is that
that my position is that
if we don't have the edibles
and it's growing part of of retail
this isn't going anywhere the state's
not going to make any money i mean this
is it without edibles today
it doesn't make sense to me at all i
mean the
the the revenue estimates that we're
getting are going to be even lower
because there's no edibles
and and i and i
and then the way the bill is right now
and then we're going to all we've done
now is put put the
the state stores in direct competition
with the
with the atcs which is not a good thing
either
so we got to figure that out maybe uh it
would shed light on that
question
of uh
our scope you know what we're into to
understand better why edibles were
excluded and uh
from this bill what what what's what
reasoning lies behind that other than
maybe
i don't know representative abbott
this project
and many people know that i was not
the most uh pro cannabis guy
out there
that's on record
in the process of doing this my goal was
to put something together that actually
has a realistic chance of getting over
the finish line
so
that
entails requiring what are deal breakers
with certain interested parties
i'm not going to speak on behalf of
anyone else but my understanding
is that if there was full edibles
allowed
this
this might not make it over the finish
line
i personally i think having if you're
going to allow recreational use
it should be for recreational use
without a restriction on who can buy
what
with the exception of an age yeah i
believe all the past but all the other
marijuana
and i think your commission included
edibles
yeah but a compromise is a compromise i
understand right it'd be better to have
nothing
and let the whole
the whole agenda fall apart on
one line on a 15-page bill i thought if
anything
that's a provision that i think we can
revisit in the future but for some
people who have been really strongly
against
recreational cannabis a lot of this
might be too much too soon
and
i think people are evolving people are
changing i'm showing the willingness to
change as people sitting on this
subcommittee that
have moved a little bit as well so
it's baby steps i know a lot of people
have already already there but not all
of us are and i think this is a fair
compromise
well
sure looks like a compromise
i mean this is what a compromise looks
like
um
but but when you think it through
it's like okay we compromised this but
ways it means we're looking at well what
kind of revenue we're going to generate
if we're going to do this what kind of
revenue we're going to generate
and if we're saying we're going to give
up phil let's just use the 50 of the
business we're going to we're going to
say no can't use it
that's just going to lower the number
big time in terms of and then
will we lose customers i mean i i just
think this through i mean if i'm i'm
there's an atc in portsmouth but i live
in you know close to maine
i just go to the store
in maine and get my product because i i
i don't like i don't want to smoke this
stuff i want to i want to have my
cookies or whatever
so
you know i agree with the logic that
you're using
and i don't i'm not sure many people
would disagree with that i think we're
going to it will the revenue side of
this will suffer if we don't have full
recreational edibles but again
we're not gonna have any revenue if this
doesn't pass and again
a compromise is a compromise and in
order to work with a lot of people
sometimes there's some provisions in
there that
if i wrote this myself and i was the
only vote and voice that mattered that i
would have wrote it the way you're
suggesting right thank you nunes has a
question so for
not not necessarily a question but maybe
just comment you know
i think
where we always fall we always fall into
the political factor
of anything that we do in this
legislature there's a political uh
outcome that may be different than what
most people want or some people want
um
but but you know we're surrounded by
states
that
have recreational um cannabis sales
and um
we had a a conversation here just a
while ago before this meeting started
says how many
people
are going to all of a sudden start using
the product because it's legalized
those people are already using the
product today it's just the money's
going somewhere else
and
um you know i know that there has to be
comfort levels for certain individuals
who are
maybe in in our body or in another body
to be able to be accepting of getting
this across the finish line and i think
that's
probably that's what i understand
part of part of the the problem is going
forward is that we've got to be able to
to get people to to believe in what
i'm willing to compromise you know make
compromises to make things happen my my
order is to stop arresting people that's
my order
and what that's what i what i'm on board
for i want i want legalization in some
fashion if this is the avenue that we
take then this is the avenue we take if
there's a better avenue then let's find
a better avenue but i think that this
bill could do a lot of good for a lot of
people even though some people think
that the state controlling it makes it a
monopoly
but when we're when when we look at
what's being done with the revenue then
it's a win for everybody in the state
so i just wanted to say that before we
got started
again i'm not advocating either way
there's a committee we could we could
say no keep keep the edibles out
keep all of that out
we just have to adjust our revenue
estimates then we have that means we're
going to have to adjust how the money
gets spent
uh you know do we do we give 25 do we
give 25 million because remember finance
is going to be involved in this
discussion as well
does it mean 25 million comes off the
top to go to uh prevention and all that
and then then
then the rest goes to or is 25 million
too much
if we're only going to bring in you know
40 million
net
tim
so around the financing i already have
some proposed language for that or some
proposed ideas around that and i guess
when we get to that number we can start
talking about it but to hershel's point
again
all of this is meaningless if it doesn't
turn into law right we can have all the
arguments we want about edibles and
everything else but if we don't you know
i'm with herschel legalization is the
conversation right stop arresting people
for for this at this point and so if i
have to baby step into this i'll baby
step into this to to make it i think you
know like herschel i'm not sure i like
the idea of a state-controlled model but
that seems to be as the governor said
this weekend right just this weekend he
thinks 1598 is the mechanism that can
get the legalization
so the more we monkey with it
that's may change that opinion and i
want to see legalization i want to get
this off the plate of cops
i want to have them you know i want to
not have our citizens be arrested and
fined um for these products um you know
i i spent 13 years in uniform and i as i
said earlier i've never been to a
domestic violence case due to marijuana
um right so that that's a fact right so
um to hershel's point i don't think all
of a sudden because we legalize it we're
going to see 50 of the population decide
all of a sudden they want to do it right
they're going to change now it's legal i
can do it i'm going to go do it i think
that the percentages aren't going to
change when it comes to edibles
my understanding is between the two
other places this has to visit after it
passes the house that may be a deal
breaker and we'd get no legalization and
herschel i think you looked up how many
bills we've the legislature's played
with since
um matt simon's here in the crowd i
think he might even have the number more
than i would have the number because he
was the lead activist here trying to
push for it for many many years
um and um i i was i was in a meeting um
not too long ago back in november uh
representative abbas you were there
and we were talking about legalization
uh it was over in manchester and
um you know i printed out i printed out
that we've had we've been introducing
cannabis legislation to this body since
and something happens every year
something happens and it and something
squashes it well
78 of the people
want it
so why don't we have it
we work for the people
so to my point i guess i i'm like
herschel it's a it's a baby step model
right we've been dealing with this for
two thousand i can't imagine the
hundreds of thousands of dollars the
legislature spent alone arguing over
this discussion um never mind all the uh
all the people have been arrested since
2003 on these products so
again um if if this is the line in the
sand edibles
i'm willing to say okay i'm fine with
keeping it the way it is or
i know there was conversation but just
removing edibles out of the liquor store
and just making it a providence of a
providence of the of the atcs and let
them sell it and just keep the flower
it's still looking at if i read this if
i do my math right we're still looking
at over 50 percent of the revenue coming
in so does the revenue model drop from
250 to 12 150 sure i mean 125 but if 125
million dollars isn't worth the
conversation um and to allow something
to go through i'm not sure what we're
talking about
okay
murphy and representative no no thank
you um
yeah obviously the um
the issue of legalization is not in our
purview right now and i would agree with
you that
you didn't see a lot of domestic
violence due to marijuana and i really
saw
car wrecks in the emergency room
secondary marijuana alone it was usually
always alcohol or some other drug beyond
marijuana so i would agree with that
part of it but
having said that
if edibles are not on the table then
simply we have to adjust our revenue
projections i mean if that's not here
and this is the baby step that we have
to take going forward then that's the
baby step we haven't taken one forward
but my
one of my concerns is
the therapeutic cannabis you know
programs in the state
and if this will in any way be harmful
to them
because in retail or in state-run stores
you're not going to have counseling
you're not going to have education so
my concern would be as long as i feel
that the therapeutic cannabis programs
are not harmed than taking a baby step
recognizing the revenue shortfalls as a
result of not having edibles seems to be
a reasonable way to proceed
so do we know do we i was under the
impression that maybe the therapeutic
cannabis programs may be in some way
harmed by this
do you know that
well they would they would if if we say
you can buy your edibles right at the
retail stores
that's that's definitely i think we
heard testimony that that'll that'll
definitely uh take customers
they say well
because it'll probably be well if it's
just sold to them
i don't know what the
the economy scale is here uh you know
but the whole goal is the state would
probably undersell under price the
we don't know but my i think pretty
strongly that
that well the state stores will unders
on the price what the atc is because
they offer more of a service than
than the retail stores won't provide any
service to what the dosage should be and
all that
so that's that's a concern and then we
need to talk about that so i agree we
have to we have to talk about do we
we keep the bill the way it is
but then we have to adjust the revenue
estimates
and then what are we going to do for the
atcs and there's two things there
this is do we take that out totally
you have to buy it from the uh
you have to buy your
edibles
at the at your atc
not in amer in the stores which means
strip out edibles totally
uh would be the first thing and then uh
it would be you know
the the re-adjusting the uh and then
do we allow
the atc's
to be the
cultivators and the
and the manufacturers
that sell to
that's the compromise we have to reach
then i'm okay with both those things to
allow
both
both the uh let the atcs have a parallel
license um to be able to sell to the
state and then additionally if if we
think that it's going to
harm the harm the medical industry i
don't think anybody here again we're
talking about 18 of the revenue
according to this this flow hub
language 18 of the revenues and edibles
again
it's to get the legalization i'll
happily give that up and and protect the
atc so they can do their product
can you react to that
i i agree with what representative lang
said about allowing the
kind of i call it the partnership
between the state and the medical
organizations i
my only comment on the harm or potential
harm to the medical
side of this is
that conversation never came up
during the public hearings on hb237
which was the sales tax transfer tax and
that would have allowed edibles
everywhere that also never came up last
year
during the hearings on hb 481
which was this similar bill as hb 237 so
but it came up big time on our company
it's only been raised it was it's not
being raised as an issue with any of the
cacrs that we're scheduled to hear
a vote on
hopefully on tuesday
if things go as scheduled it only seems
to be brought up in
in respect to 1598. so
i understand that there may be some
overlap
i'm i'm going to say that i assume if
someone is is
using cannabis for legitimate medical
reasons i do not understand why that
person would all of a sudden stop going
to a medical facility
and now start just buying it at a
recreational store if there's other
benefits that that they receive that are
not going to be offered in the retail
store it seems to me
that it wouldn't make sense that person
would no longer go and receive the full
benefits
that's just my understanding also just
because it's an edible it doesn't mean
that it's medical grade so my
understanding is products can be
specifically
medical grade products and if the if the
medical facilities do not want to sell
the medical grade to the state that is
their
as the manufacturer that's their choice
we want to hear from atc's on that right
okay so
thank you thank you for that
um yeah you can you can yeah
we may have you come back up of course
but
my only concern is that price point
would be a competitive reason for acts
to be a problem
yeah the uh i just i guess i'm sort of
methodical about things like this and i
i think the uh it seems to me that the
um first question that i asked about
whether we're going to
consider taking
the prohibition
is the threshold question and my senses
is that we're not and it's either
because
there's a ruling that it's part of the
policy that came to us which i kind of
think it was
and uh and is
or
um
we don't want to take it out because we
can see that it's an essential piece of
the compromise that was built
to get this bill to us but uh but if
we're over that
let's set that
behind us
and look at this bill and see uh
a number of things
how that plays out in terms of the
revenue is obviously a big piece of
a big consequence of that decision and
uh
and with
i i will we'll get to the revenue
numbers but i i heard that 250 million
dollars a moment coming down 125 million
dollars and i guess
there's a lot of persuasion that's going
to need to be done just give me two
revenues at that higher level
all right so i think what we'll do is if
we can do this we'll take little mini
votes here to see where we're at
on this um
i mean is there anyone who wants to
tamper with
adding edibles back into the bill for
recreational i does anybody want to
and i i i see no hands
so that that's a threshold does it want
to or is it a reasonable way to proceed
to get to an end you know compromise
are we going to be blocked if we pursue
that we can always revisit it right but
i i
my sense from the conversation was
that let's not touch that
what's going to happen then when we go
to our revenue discussion
that's going to be a big variable okay
we know
that's not going to be added back in
because we we've agreed that's not going
to be added back in so
is that as they are it's going to stay
as as it came to us right but we'll
proceed through this we may come to a
point where we say oh my goodness
right right
but that that helps so right
and then you can come back and say what
if
okay
well basically that's that's what we're
going to try to do so
so
the
um
yeah so i mean i guess we'd have to do
the same thing as we i mean harm to the
atc's
technically is in our revenue thing it's
harm to the atcs
somewhere i i think we have to have the
exactly what i was going to bring up
that um
you know when
where i i don't think we're talking just
about edibles as a whole
we're talking about
edibles being provided at the public at
the state-run retail outlet that is in
direct competition
with the atc's and their business
that was put in statute by us right okay
so um so i think that we have to we have
to get to that conversation and and to
determine
uh is it is it in
is it in their favor is it in our favor
what's going to happen with that i
believe hb 605 was the bill that allowed
cross state
um
uh sales from medical is that correct
that's it's not in effect yet though
correct and
is that it's a rules thing if i'm not
mistaken it's hung up in rules thank you
very much for your nods back there i
remember uh your you being present
able to do that
and um
and those
those the pricing that may be in place
for them and this is all subjective
but um may take care of what could be
sold in this in a state-run facility
next door to a liquor store or wherever
it's going to be placed
because of because of pricing they may
already be coming ready to come across
the border to buy from them so um
the other part of this is uh
when you look at the consumer base of
people who are going to come into a
state facility
and they see that
edibles can be sold to one
piece of the public but not to another
uh there's going to be an issue
yeah so let's let's try to resolve that
okay
so
let's move forward okay
my uh third point
was
page six when you say
this is something that i i
wanna do
page
and i when you look at the um
page five when you look at
um
oh it's it's page five third lines
thirty to thirty seven and page six uh
lines one to fifteen has to do with the
um
rules
and it seems like a
really tight time frame
to get the rules done
i'll ask you
tim um i mean you're on jail car
but where we assume the bill is signed
and if it passes it's signed in
june or something like that
by october 1st the commission has to
adopt rules
that seems like a really tight time
frame
to do it the reason i think it's related
to revenue that it it may take longer
than that and the revenue won't start
flowing
um because of that
so
tim you're being on gel car do you have
a comment on that i agree i think i
think they're the
putting dates in here
are probably problematic
hard dates um i i think again if we're
know
car putting i think i'm trying to
remember the process for public hearings
and notice
and and
and all of those kind of things i
remember it's almost a six-month process
for a rule to go from
the commission puts forward a rule and
then all the public hearings that have
to occur and all the votes that have to
occur it's almost six months from start
to finish
um and so this would be a little
problematic i'd be more inclined to just
saying by you know december 31st which
gives them six months you know from from
the time the law is adopted to be able
to get the rules and it means they have
to hustle a little bit but it's probably
doable i do agree that the october 1st
deadline is probably too tight for
jalcar to be able to get everything done
do you recommend that we just take the
date out
put it put us put it extend it a little
bit
i would uh
what were you saying give me one second
give me one minute to read that and see
how i think i could be better
uh
if i can just interject here that
it's not necessarily that there are time
frames that jalka has to meet
but
as representative lang's offering if if
we put in a date of december first
december 31st it allows for that time
frame and and these
departments and commissions need to get
their job done you know and and they
tend to i know you've experienced this
they tend to lengthen the process
and
uh well it's actually let's put them on
the point
liquor has to meet that deadline and
then eventually goes to jail car
somewhat upset
i strike the first whole sentence and
just put
no later than december 31st 2022 the
commission shall adopt rules pursuant to
well i think it it's important because
it has to do with when they can get
we know we if they don't have rules
we're not going to start revenue
generation
right and so
you can't open a store until you've got
the rules around the store so we have to
have some sort of timeline for them to
be able to adapt so we can if we put
this in place we can start estimating
somebody agree with that
anybody
okay
oh sure
uh
so this uh the regulations
here talk about the registration of
cannabis establishments so rules for
that
and then in another part of the bill
the liquor commission is given licensing
authority right to issue licenses
cannabis licenses is on page 12 in the
middle
starting at line 16. right
and so we got registration
the first part of the bill under one of
the statutes
which is uh i think at the title
the numbers but uh and then we've got
page six you're talking page six line uh
is that where you are
well two places we've got what we were
just looking at right page five
and the registration is for the
uh
our rules relative to the registration
and regulation of cannabis
establishments
and
i believe
there's a registration requirement for
each of the types of cannabis
establishments somewhere else
but
that doesn't mesh with the language
that's used for the
liquor commission on page 12 which is
licensure language
i just don't square it so it's a
actually the licensure language is on um
is on page if you look look at page six
line
down so it says the liquor commission
shall
accept a accept and process applications
beginning no later than may 1st
for cannabis cultivation facilities
right
and beginning no later than august 1st
of 2023
for cannabis product manufacturing
facilities cannabis transporters and
cannabis testing facilities what are the
issues
is your registration application 90 days
of the application the rules we're just
talking about that so mr chair if i mean
so again this is a chicken and egg kind
of situation is that we have to adopt
rules the rules would include what the
forms look like for registration all of
those kind of things and then they can
begin to accept and process applications
so
again
where we're talking about first they
have to establish the guidelines and the
rule you know the rules the rule making
on the five on under 541a
and establish all of the things that
this bill is going to do
they have to they have to create rules
because that's generally what we do is
we give it we give authority to an
agency to make rules to implement the
law we just passed
and then it's up for them to just to
figure that out and bring it to job car
um and usually it involves several
conversations with lots of people i know
when we were doing the sports betting
rules we're doing historic horse racing
rules a lot of conversation with
legislators about legislative intent and
about conversations around those kind of
things so they can adapt the rules to
meet what the len
the law says
and so i think here you're talking about
when they can start processing
applications but the real rule-making
authority and and i do agree we have two
different sections where rule making is
is talked about we have the section that
we were just talking about on page
five and the regulation of cannabis and
adopting rules and then we have another
so there are two sets of rule making and
i think the second set of rule making is
a little more detailed than the first
but again remember the agency's
requirement is to implement all rules
for the entire law
so even if we limit it in here somehow
and they go well wait in order to do
this we have to
put a regulation around investigations
they'll have a whole separate even
though we don't tell them they have to
do rule making on it it's part of the
law and the passage of the law so
they'll adopt that anyway well if i may
respond um it's i think it's a simple
problem to resolve as i said i think
it's probably a drafting issue and you
could simply say on line 33 of page five
the
commission shall adopt rules regarding
relative to the registration licensure
and regulation
of all
cannabis
establishments and
it's just just line 33 of page five pick
up licensure
because that's the term that's going to
be used as they go out and actually
license and it's the traditional term
that's used so where's this research
around what
add regulation
yeah
then we can get rid of the section in
the back no you leave you leave the rest
that's an amendment to the commission's
basic
statute yeah
oh right we're reading right now they've
got a whole list of licensure
obligations okay yeah okay that's that's
that one then
since it's may of may 1st of 2012 and
this is this is when they do all the
forms and everything else that they have
that all that rule making
has to be done by may 1st for the
cultivation facilities
i'm on page six
uh line
line 21 through
24.
so again mr chair just point out it says
no later then
versus a hard date which means that if
we finish the rules in december and
jalcar votes on in january they can
start accepting applications in february
so once the rules are set then they can
they can proceed so that that's fine but
i guess i do need to follow up
what is the difference between
we're using two terms here so it gets
really confusing
here you know the obligation is to issue
a registration which
is clear within 90 days at the receipt
of an application
well where does licensure come in well
wouldn't it be that the registration is
simply the form that you put forward to
say i want to open this
shop whatever it is licensure comes to
your your evaluation of whether the shop
does it right whether it's you know
the type of milligrams in there that
sort of thing you're right i think it's
applying they're applying to
to be a cultivator let's say
then if they meet all the requirements
they have the background checks and all
that yeah then then they would get then
they would qualify to
be licensed right right
um
well it'd be good to say
somewhere
okay
all right again that that one that one's
way off ways it means yeah but and i
brought it up though so it's but i think
we picked up a few things here that we
need to do so
i want to keep on going because we want
to try to go no later than 12 30 today
um line six
on on
main page six
lines twenty one that
i had to put it somewhere 21-23
the one thing that we
when we talk about the actual license
and i know tim and i chat about this
earlier but um offline
there's no there's no fee schedule in
there
what a cultivator license would be
initial and then subsequent years
same thing with the
reta there's no retail the retailers
don't have a license because they're
part of the state
but we the the cultivators the testers
and the manufacturers licenses and
transport i guess there's a transporter
license in here
there's no fee schedule
and
i don't know i guess the question is
this is no fee schedule we can't
estimate
what those revenues would be it won't be
compared to the total it won't be big
big
i'm trying to find my hand out from the
marijuana report
i have to
hear mr chair so when i when i is this
one you're looking at here this this
tabling thing this will give you a sense
you know these are from a couple years
ago
uh let me let me take colorado
um
there's an application fee and then a
license fee let's just talk about the
license fee
um alaska
cultivation a thousand to five thousand
manufacturing a thousand to five five
thousand
retail five thousand testing a thousand
i'll pick i'll pick um one more
you know massachusetts being
application fee 3000
maximum
[Music]
of 15
000 for cultivator manufacturer retail
a license and testing maximum of 10 000.
they must have some variable thing in
there
so i mean those are kind of ranges that
you're that you're dealing with
we had suggested
application fees
for
all different kind of licenses that is
the ability to ask to be
considered to have a license
and then once you get approved for the
license
uh we said retail but we're not talking
about retail here but that was ten
thousand to fifteen thousand initial
year
six thousand to nine thousand subsequent
years
testing
five thousand seventy five hundred
initial year three thousand to uh for
forty five hundred
um
et cetera i mean i i i
so
i guess when you're in the grand scheme
of things i guess in the grand scheme of
things
it's not going to skew our revenue
estimates that much look at it
if i made mr chair again because we talk
about in the bill that has a limit on
cultivators 15.
if i do the math it's basically if you
had somebody if you had one unique
cultivator manufacturing testing times
15 we're talking 165 000 a year
would be the maximum revenue at 15
cultivators 15 manufacturers and 15
testing facilities
um and again i think that number is
not significant although i hate to say
that people think that 165 thousand
dollars is insignificant but
but
yeah i think in the grand scheme of of
this bill it's not a significant issue
and i will say that the legislature
historically at least recently
has been putting more and more onus on
the department that developed the life
the fee schedules i know that fishing
game i just passed a bill to change the
hike safe card take the fees schedule
out of let of statute and give it give
541a recommendation so that the agency
can be dynamic and adjust and adapt
based on what's going on we did the same
thing in oplc
we gave them some rule making authority
to be able to create their own licensing
structure with the provision that the
licensing structure has to be
uh lack the paraphrase and
not-for-profit model right that it has
to cover the cost of licensing and the
cost of
of of the process of
registration or licensing so i think
it'd be probably inconsistent with the
history of the legislature over the
recent years to start putting hard fixed
costs for licensing into the bill itself
well traditionally we do get
those
but maybe less now i don't know i mean
the hike the hike safeguard
came to waste him he's years ago when it
was first issued and we actually we we
just signed off someone came up with a
fee and we signed off on that fee level
uh way back when um but anyway
so i i for the purposes of this
discussion
it you know
in the background it's a hundred
thousand or maybe 150 000
additional revenue but it's not going to
be the deal breaker for this bill
i think so whatever
again the bill
doesn't have fees i guess it assumes
what you were just saying representative
and that that
that the elected commission would come
up with their free
schedules all right
so let's move on
uh number five
this goes back to the ac atc's i sorry
for my typo there
um
i'm gonna have a yeah
just thinking about that
isn't that true that the liquor
commission
fee schedules for
its other licensing act it's a current
law licensing activities are specified
in the statute right now yes they're in
the statute three pages so here we are
just
proposing to hand it over to the liquor
commission with no legislative direction
you know that's certainly an option but
that's not what traditionally has
happened
no i i think ways and means should weigh
in but myself uh what maybe we need to
spend a little more time on that um
i have no idea what the numbers would be
but uh because the fees
i mean we were
we represent the people as legislature
in some way that we should weigh in on
these fees
if we think they're unreasonable
that you know if we leave it to the
agency
are they being reasonable or not
they don't they don't directly report to
the p we do not not them
so
um
i mean
yeah i was surprised it was in the feed
schedule and that's why i brought it up
i you know i thought there'd be a fee
schedule in it
um
and i can't i can't speak for the other
states whether it was in their statutes
or they came up with the fees in another
way i don't know
but mr chair yeah so i i can tell you
again over in jaipur
we've
denied um
rulemaking based on we thought the fees
were too high and we've we've uh we've
we've sent it back for rulemaking to
adjust the fees so remember any any fees
that are set have to come in front of
jalcar does have a legislative process
for the setting of fees uh through
jalcar
and again they're under the their
agencies are under that component of it
can't be our for-profit making system
they have to justify their fees and
expenses so
it allows them again to be adaptive
because a fee set this year may be
completely different than a fee that's
needed five years from now because with
inflation economy and everything else
that's going on nobody knows
so if we hard code this
into statute we're going to have this
argument in five years
so that's the reason why the agencies
have generally been left now to the
ability to
if they want to make a rule change to
change a fee they have to come in front
of jalcar and prove why the fee is now
goes from a thousand dollars to fifteen
hundred dollars whatever it is but i
think by
i'm not sure that where have the
expertise or the or the uh
uh know how to set what we think the fee
should be so it's not a money making
opportunity i have no idea what it would
cost liquor to
investigate and license somebody
well this is certainly uh
no one wrote us a memo to say that this
was
that this was this the sea change in
the way fees because traditionally i've
been you know
represented major's been around a long
time
i've been here 12 years
we always we always get bills that have
fees in them that we they come to us to
to adjudicate one way or another
um so i i guess i need to get a sense of
the committee
do we just want to not worry about the
fees because they're not in the bill
or do we want to address the fees
i mean
i'll ask it to
who wants who wants to address the fees
anybody
who doesn't want justice
i guess
i guess the real question is do we want
to leave the fees to rule making or do
we want to set the fees in statute
that's kind of the question yeah well
right that was yeah so you know
if it's my opinion again i'd rather
leave it to rulemaking to allow the
agency to be dynamic and adjust as it
goes along and it still has the
rule-making process to be able to if we
don't like it we can shut it down
could we
find a middle road that would identify
parameters that the
commission would work on for fees
that would be you know you sort of
alluded to the parameters you say jr
jailcar
looks to when it reviews these things
could we put in some words i don't know
what i did haven't looked at this is
there anything at all in the in the bill
right now on uh
standards for
setting fees
the only fee i see in here is this one
that's on page six line 19 which is for
go to 250 dollars to the municipality
that's the only fixed fee i see in in
here i'd have no objection would just
say that
again under the rule making authority we
can just put a line in it says
fees will be adopted
i don't know again not not to make a
profit i don't know how we would word
so
um
i just want to keep this moving along so
that
we
i'm just trying to stay in my my my
points here so
the atcs
um
we got to know
what
we can and can't do
with the atcs
from the standpoint of
allowing them to
in terms of
of being manufactured being cultivators
being able to apply to be cultivators
and apply to be manufacturers
and even apply to be transporters
to get those licenses
to
um
you know by the way
i want to get to the transport apart but
so i need to hear from the atc's can can
someone uh
good morning
appreciate you
giving me the opportunity to speak for
the record matt simon i've been with
prime atc since last summer prior to
that i spent 10 years working with the
marijuana policy project was involved in
efforts to pass adult use legalization
laws in
all three neighboring states and
elsewhere as well so i have multiple
perspectives here and certainly worked
with the study commission quite a bit
back in the back in the day
a couple just general comments and then
i'll try to respond to all the questions
that i that i've heard so far and if i
forget any of them please re-ask them uh
in general
we believe the best approach to adult
use cannabis legalization is more or
less what was recommended by the study
commission a reasonably regulated free
market approach with relatively low low
taxes and an independent
cannabis commission
hb 1598 is not that it is not our
preferred approach to legalization at
all
i have serious questions about whether
it's a workable policy some of which
you've already
begun to ask but since it has passed the
house and we're here in this committee i
appreciate that your many of you are
trying to find ways to make this work
trying to find ways to understand how it
would impact the tcp and the atcs
and i'm here to participate in those
discussions
and
so
you've heard the concerns and how do we
another general comment so
all of the revenue related questions to
me come back to one
overarching question which is what kind
of market are we talking about creating
is this a market that people are going
to want to shop at or is it a market
that they're not
so it's important to look at what the
neighboring states have done
massachusetts is a relatively free
market system but it's a very corporate
system with high barriers to entry the
prices are somewhat higher there
that being said the market is maturing
prices are coming down they've been at
it several years i checked last week
there are now 387
licensed adult use retailers in
massachusetts there are 296
licensed cultivators
there are 225 licensed manufacturers of
cannabis products
so the stores that are along the
right across the border many of them
will have products from 5 10 15
different companies consumers who are
able to pay the premiums and there is a
tax associated with it but they have a
market that has many selections for them
maine has prioritized craft cannabis
from the very beginning uh they've had
caregivers growing cannabis since 1999.
caregivers can serve five patients so
they've been growing a fair amount of
cannabis and a few years ago they all
got the ability to basically open
storefronts and serve patients directly
so it is a very
less regulated market than new hampshire
has
and all of those caregivers they made it
easy for them to get into the adult use
market the adult use market just opened
last fall
but it is already very robust i spent a
few days in portland last week i got a
receipt from one of the stores did a
little shopping talked to some people
trying to get some perspective
prices are already lower than
massachusetts even though they've just
opened
they have 77 retail stores in maine
58 cultivators
and 35 manufacturers with active
licenses
and that's only being up a few months i
think that number will be triple in a
year
they will have a lot of
supply and a very robust market full of
options for consumers so
we already hear from patients in new
hampshire who are registered they only
have three companies to choose from in
new hampshire they have thousands of
caregivers to choose from in maine
those caregivers don't have to have
their products independently lab tested
and they don't have anywhere near the
kinds of startup costs and overhead
costs that
we do so a lot of our patients do go to
maine and we we understand that on the
so
my point is that they have a huge head
start vermont is a little bit behind
them they haven't opened retail stores
yet but that will also be a very free
market system relative to what we're
talking about here this is frankly the
least free market approach to
legalization that's ever been considered
in any state and that is fundamentally
the reason i think
it will not produce
the successful results that
some believe in terms of
you know capturing the illicit market or
in terms of producing revenue
going back to study commission i think
one of the best pieces of advice the
study commission received was from
colorado andrew friedman was the first
regulator and what he said was if you're
doing this solely for the money you're
doing it for the wrong reason
so that's priority is revenue for the
state
it's always been pretty much the bottom
of my list i think there's a lot of
really good things that are accomplished
by effective cannabis regulation
transitioning illicit market into a
regulated market protecting consumers
giving consumers access to a regulated
safe product providing education public
education
the opportunity to try to create a
culture of responsible use around
cannabis which prohibition absolutely
does not do
people buy cannabis from illicit dealers
they're introduced to an illicit market
that might try to sell them other things
and uh they certainly don't know what
they're getting they don't know if it's
covered in pesticides they don't know if
it's five percent thc or 25 thc so i see
an opportunity for a really successful
policy here and i'm encouraged to hear
some talk about revenue not being the
main the main goal but i know that it is
a main goal for others and i know it's
focused for this committee so we have to
so this brings us around to here we are
i don't know if this is going to work i
don't know if 15
cultivators
i've become pretty familiar with the
different types of cannabis businesses
and there's a pretty good analogy to be
made to beer
we're all familiar with the large
corporate beer scene and we know that
there is craft brewing new hampshire
takes great pride in its craft breweries
we have a bunch of them everybody likes
them
we recognize that the quality is a lot
higher in vermont the way they framed
this over the course of years
policymakers kept talking do we want to
create the budweiser of cannabis or do
we want to create the heady topper of
cannabis
and what they wound up with was a bill
that
very much privileges craft cannabis
small cultivators they have six
cultivation tiers the lowest smallest
here is very accessible very easy for
anybody to to get involved with so
that would be what would be attracted
here because any company that's going to
risk a market where there's only one
buyer and that buyer is the laker
commission
there's nothing in the bill that says
they have to buy your product
federal legalization could happen next
year open up interstate commerce liquor
commission could simply follow its
existing model they could import
cannabis from wherever it's the cheapest
we never have to have a cannabis
business in new hampshire some people
might think that's a good thing i happen
to think that the jobs and economic
opportunities and are
an important part of legalization and
they're certainly part of the revenue
conversation if you want to have
cultivators and manufacturers that are
paying business profits and business
enterprise tax
so
i worry about the overall market i worry
that as represent former representative
hannon said that it will be perceived as
government cheese relative to the free
market craft cannabis models in
neighboring states and i think that's a
huge risk
from us as an atc perspective could we
expand and supply this market
we have some ability to expand our
biggest constraint on that is our
non-profit status that limits our access
to cap
let's talk about that so that's a big
issue from our perspective
if we're going to be allowing 15 of the
largest publicly traded cannabis
companies to move into new hampshire and
set up corporate cannabis and tell the
atcs that they have to remain non-profit
and that is
not going to work and we're just not
going to be able to
support that if that's what's moving
forward
but if we are able to transition to
for-profit uh that would give us the
access to capital we would be able to
expand and be one of the suppliers
for this system
uh would that get us to neutral on the
bill i don't know but we're we're happy
to talk about what it might look like
and there was a bill to do
that bill didn't pass did it
605 did that pass
605 is out of state sales so the
for-profit bill the last one was sb 38
it was vetoed by the governor
it uh
it was overridden by the senate and was
two votes short in the house but i do
actually have a copy of the governor's
veto statement i think it's really worth
looking at because it
raises some important issues and and to
be clear our position on this is very
nuanced and i
prime was neutral on sb 38
within the context of having regional
for-profit monopolies that are dictated
by the state that we're the only people
i was a little uncomfortable with that i
supported i've been a supporter of the
non-profit status all along because
we're only allowing three companies to
operate in the space and i thought it
made sense that they should have to be
non-profits but that being said
what other business produces things and
sells them and has to be a non-profit
salvation army is the only one that i
can think of can
maybe maybe somebody else knows one but
i
it's it's really difficult
so in the context of allowing
for-profit businesses to operate in new
hampshire if you let them do it you
should let the atcs do it
that's our view okay
so
but okay so there's two steps to that so
i'm sorry
so there's two steps to that first
that would be that on your mind it would
only work if we
we made them for-profits
they could be able to compete that way
uh
and
obviously they would have to increase
capacity on the growing and probably the
manufacturing side
um
as well is that correct oh yes so
we'd have to know what what what
would have to change in the statutes to
allow that to happen
um
i know you're representing one
one
right i can only speak for myself in
prime atc i know michael holt is back
there from the therapeutic cannabis
program and you may be able to comment
on some of the specifics of how
two regulatory regimes
might work i think it can be made to
work i i don't think it's the best way
to do it because well here's the other
the other thing that we had
in the cannabis in the marijuana we call
the marijuana commission then you know
we're no
more pc we call it the right name
cannabis
so
um
we talked about giving a pathway
in that in that report we gave the
pathway for the
atcs to be able to also sell
recreational
one thing we said you have to separate
the sides of the store
and have two separate entrances i think
that was the main the main thing can you
just talk about that what you're seeing
in other states like you mentioned maine
massachusetts how are they handling that
how do they
how are they working side by side with
the atcs or are they
yeah thank you for the question uh
every state except one that i'm aware of
has managed to maintain a viable
therapeutic cannabis market and the way
they've done that primarily has been by
allowing dispensaries to transition and
engage in adult use sales if you do that
correctly it increases the economies of
scale you're able to offer cheaper
cannabis not only to adult consumers but
do that i think there should be rules
that require the therapeutic cannabis
dispensaries to continue serving
patients
there have been a few other states where
prices have gone up for patients as a
result of this and that's you know i i
believe the prime would voluntarily make
sure that didn't happen but that doesn't
mean you shouldn't make rules
requiring us not to harm patients
uh by prioritizing
the other marketplace right but where
we're at i mean this bill
is the state runs the retail stores so
right i don't see how that how do we how
do we mesh
i think we have two competing things
with under the state umbrella here
where
the atcs are technically competing with
the these yes typically new retail
stores can you just comment on that
number i can't and to be clear since
representative abbott mentioned the
previous bills both hb 481 and 237 i
just looked up 237 there are 11
references to alternative treatment
center they it explains it assumes that
we would be able to sell cannabis so we
are included in that model and that's
why i think you didn't hear the atc's
object so given if we're not going to
allow atcs to sell cannabis we have to
find another way to
to make this work and
uh
it's at least theoretically possible
that a limited license model that only
allows
i just don't see how three
cultivators
are going to be able to produce enough
product
without compromising quality i mean it's
it's easy to say you're going to grow
five times as much as you're already
growing and not
compromise any quality on this very
sensitive agricultural product the
reality is i mean we did a major
expansion last fall
completed it last december and it it
took i don't know six months eight
months before
all the new systems were dialed in and
everybody was really comfortable with it
so it's a big it's going to be perceived
as a business risk by i think any
cultivator that each company each of the
three companies has their own
cultivation facility correct
one facility each yeah they use one
some have recently expanded okay
so and so they're all under the lights
right
not not yes they're all under lights and
that's another issue the main business
owner i talked to last week they have
both the medical and they're wholesaling
into the adult use market they have a
greenhouse that's solely for medical and
they have a greenhouse that's solely for
adult use and we're not currently able
to operate greenhouses right in new
hampshire
thank you um
in other states that have both adult
sale and also cannabis or therapeutic or
atc type models
are they merged in most of the states
right now and if not other licensures
different between the two and
how onerous is that a difference in
licensure requirements
so in the vast majority of cases
there's an option
the the medical cannabis dispensaries
can remain medical only or they can
transfer to adult use only or they can
remain
dual use and and have a situation such
as representative romney mentioned with
separate interests and separate separate
counters
it's
all three neighboring states have opted
for independent cannabis commissions
that regulate all things cannabis so
the vermont cannabis control board is
assumed responsibility of medical
cannabis as part of that transition
and they're regulating all all cannabis
and in maine it's the office of
marijuana policy and massachusetts is
the cannabis control commission
uh in in all those cases
it part of the transition was to unify
all cannabis regulation under one office
and i think it makes all the sense in
the world uh there's yet another reason
that hadn't come up that i wasn't aware
of until a year ago but it's the hemp
derived thc products that are now
proliferating other states are cracking
down on them there's a vape shop two
blocks from my house that will sell you
delta eight thc
vape cartridges which are absolutely
psychoactive somewhat less psychoactive
than delta nine but they're readily
available i don't know if they check ids
a whole bunch of them on the wall so
other states are cracking down on that i
think we should have regulation of it
that's another reason that a
cannabis commission that regulates all
things cannabis to me is by far the most
sensible approach to policy and the one
that most states have been following and
developing
so if those states are now and our
surrounding states are all controlled by
a governing board that then can regulate
the product both adult use and
therapeutic use what have what have our
neighboring states or across the country
seen in the use of the black market i
mean have they seen a decrease in that
or
uh or not it takes time to change
consumer attitudes and behaviors i i
would say
vermont doesn't have any stores open so
they haven't eliminated the illicit
market except by giving people the
option to grow at home which eliminates
maine
i think a lot of people would describe
that more of a gray market situation
with so many caregivers and
there there's a lot of
there are a lot of storefronts and
there's a lot of informal cannabis
commerce that happens that probably
isn't ideal and
less regulation
um so it's it's
everybody understands that maine is
supplying
the region with a lot of it's a
significant amount of its its cannabis
but when you hear the talking point that
regulated adult use doesn't eliminate
the black market and you know despite
colorado selling billions of dollars
worth of cannabis how does that make
things worse
people are conflating
the the market of coloradans
who consume cannabis and the the
national market for cannabis which is
still prohibition in the vast majority
of states so
there are
criminally minded individuals who have
bought houses in colorado as soon as it
became legal and thought ah i'm going to
grow a whole house full of cannabis here
i'm going to ship it to new hampshire
and i'll be able to do that under the
nobody will notice because there's so
much legal cannabis and
well
people do notice they get charged with
felonies and
there's been a lot of enforcement around
this trip they strip all the everything
out right of the house
the problem is those lights at night put
the lights in keep you up so just one
and they do that here too i mean we've
had whole house grows busted in new
hampshire just to follow a follow-up it
would is a revenue question actually
have in your experience or others
experienced in the country seen with the
increased regulation and
commission
control of cannabis use across the
country have they seen in any state a
decrease in the alcohol consumption or
purchasing because that's obviously a
big revenue portion of our budget so
have they ever seen has that been
correlated um frankly i was hoping that
would happen i think cannabis is
objectively much safer than alcohol so
that would i think that be beneficial it
hasn't generally it's it's been a very
negligible and what would you say is 12
to 15
of this population i will actually
consume cannabis is that
there's different reports on that i mean
it
it's not for everybody
absolutely
it would never approach it never
approach alcohol i don't know no i mean
they're it's it's complicated the
reasons that people choose not to
consume cannabis i'm never sure whether
people rarely face a pure choice uh
between alcohol and cannabis without
other factors
involved and big the biggest ones being
drug testing for employment and
fear of a social stigma people have
family members who would judge them for
cannabis use don't judge them for
drinking bourbon
we're still there thc stays in your
system a long time
that's fine i mean you're not
you're not uh impaired but it's there
it's detected for if you get a blood
test or just 10 minutes
so i just want to get back to where we
started this conversation
so would you your organization would be
in favor if we were to amend this bill
to allow the atcs to be able to
cultivate and sell to the state through
a parallel licensing program
i didn't say in favor i think
neutrality is
the closest the best that we could
possibly support
hb629 which would allow home grow and
possession we're all for that one
creating a market is is
there a lot of issues here and uh i i
we're a long way from supporting it so
i'll rephrase you won't oppose the idea
of allowing the option for the atcs to
be able to sell to the state
you wouldn't oppose that
i'm i'm here to discuss what that might
look like but we are opposed to the bill
until we see an amendment that gets us
somewhere else
trying to craft language for the
amendment it'd be nice to know if i
appreciate that representative
mike are you willing to come up in a
minute mike
to safety
i was echoing uh representative lang
here we're we're talking about
not about full retail sales for the atcs
but we're talking about cultivation for
sales to the state and manufacturing
products yeah and manufacturing
yeah so and transportation so um i just
want to make sure that that's what we
were talking about here
there are a number of risks associated
with entering that market one is is will
this program even get off the ground due
to legal concerns no state has ever
it's hard to evaluate the risk that your
market won't even materialize all right
before you go left
you have a question for
uh
identifiers are a system for tracking
marijuana
this spill i don't think there's
anything like that
can you speak to the important
yeah we've never really needed too much
of a tracking system in new hampshire
because we only have the three companies
and we have very strict rules about how
we can transport and there's limited uh
interactions between them
but if we're moving to a
robust free market system there would
need to be some way to track that
product and other states have generally
uh found there are a few software
systems that that already exist that
seem to work pretty well for that
the main caregivers have resisted it
because they they would add costs to
them so that's one state where there
isn't track and trace and there's kind
of a wild northeast
market in a sense but all the other
states pretty much
found that to be important and have done
that and the commission the commission
report four years ago recommended a
tracking system
assuming a recreational market i'm not
i don't know how we evaluate how that
fits into our task here but i just
is really also a note is what you were
just talking about at the end that this
is a unique
structure that's being proposed here in
new hampshire and it's unparalleled
canada comes close
but
there are big differences
the law is different uh the federal law
i mean
is different so it's permitted you don't
have this
uh
constraint of going across boundaries
and
over over
the overhang of possible prosecution of
people
from the federal side
and then i think it's been more
progressive the canadian law
allows for
choices whether it will be
the province running the retail owning
the
retail stores or making them private i
think they've had varied experience i've
looked at that stuff and i don't really
see that
it's that helpful in evaluating this
because it's so varied and it's
again the federal overlay is so
different would you come into that yeah
like you i looked into canada tried to
make some sense of what was happening
there i haven't followed it as closely
as the united states
totally different system they legalized
nationally and then left each province
to come up with their own
system and a couple of provinces uh
attempted to implement state-run stores
it was confounded by a number of things
and i i don't i agree with you i don't
think we can learn anything definitive
from that experience i think we can
learn more from the other states that
have
preceded us and
if you know if the goal is to capture as
much of the illicit market and
transition it to a regulated market as
quickly as we can
you need to have
accessible stores only having 10 of them
is going to limit sales and limit
revenue and only having 15 suppliers is
going to limit consumer options actually
i guess the bill isn't i i misspoke in
the hearing last last week that
the ten is for for uh
the uh fiscal note purposes that's
unbounded but but that that's unbounded
but they bound the the cultivators to
15.
so i don't know how that works but you
know on the bill we
limit the cultivators to 15
but the number of retails could be
whatever number we can handle
usually usually that's the free market
who's dictating that for both so so i
guess just to
conclude my little piece here that
i'm left feeling that
we're gonna we have to struggle with a
totally different model and how that
plays in because i think that model is
given it's coming to us in this bill we
have to
work with it
but what does that mean in terms of
revenue and
we've got a lot of unknowns playing out
here it's uh
it's unprecedented there's no other
state that does it this way
how does that affect revenues i don't
know we've got a liquor commissioner we
all
think they do a great job with liquor
but with liquor they're working off of a
supply on top of a wholesale supply
system that is worldwide
and
you know if it falters here it's going
to be strong enough there they're going
to always have a good supply and they
can work on top of that
and be clever and they are
and it's a storable product i don't know
whether that makes a difference we
haven't talked about marijuana and how
it has to be
dealt with over
periods of time when maybe the market's
going up and down um
but uh but that's our challenge oh no we
got a reaching challenge yeah
okay i'm going to keep on moving here so
all right thank you very much man
appreciate it
mike can you come up we'll be real quick
with you here
um
why don't you expect why don't you
explain your role and then what we
really want to know is what do you think
in terms of
if we if we were to
open up this to
the atcs how how does that how do we do
that
and do we have to make them for-profits
to do that what what do you think in
terms of this let me first explain your
role yeah thank you my name is michael
holt i'm the administrator for the
therapeutic cannabis program with the
department of health and human services
been running the program for a number of
years um
the
the department has concerns about this
bill and this model obviously i'm
concerned about the viability of the
atcs under this model and thus if the
viability of the atcs is threatened then
the viability of the therapeutic
cannabis program is uh is at risk as
well
um as matt started saying or said you
know
most
states who have a medical and a
recreational market have been able to
maintain both markets um and there is uh
there is value to a medical market um
some of the principles that under that
that
underpin the value of a medical market
available to people under 21.
they allow higher potency products than
a recreational market does
they offer strains and product types
oriented to a medical market
they provide robust education
campaigns to to patients
most importantly
medical programs don't tax cannabis and
recreational product programs do tax
if under this model the point is to
undercut a regional price and make this
a money maker then
patients are patients are going to where
it's cheapest they're not going to the
place that
that requires extra cost they're not
talking to their doctors about their use
of this for a medical purpose they're
absolutely going to the cheapest price
point um we're see we see this in in
maine you know people go across the
border to maine because it's an
unregulated market we know our patients
are going across the border
so without a tax a taxable model i'm
concerned about the viability
so what might help the viability of the
atcs
allowing them to enter a record this
recreational market so they can at least
stay in business and also serve the the
the medical market as well
um how we do that
reinsert senate bill 38 perhaps into
this bill um and allow a for-profit
conversion
um as is a possible way of doing that
um
right now you know my
the issue of edibles or rather we're
using edibles as a stand-in for cannabis
infused products so there's a whole
range of cannabis infused products that
are not edibles uh you said topicals
topicals are cannabis infused products
and that they're not flour not
concentrates so this bill would
put
this
at first it's important to say that this
bill recriminalizes the possession of
cannabis infused products for the
general population right now they are
decriminalized this bill would
recriminalize an adult you know uh
possessing a cannabis infused product
bought by another state
um and so there's fiscal
issues related to that you know because
now it's it's recriminalized
um
this bill allows the uh the state stores
to sell
these cannabis-infused products directly
to the therapeutic cannabis patients
so if the bill is to not have edibles
then allowing these state stores to have
edibles to me sounds like another nail
in the coffin for atcs um it's taking
away that possibility of the um
the atc's to retain some of the market
um so if the bill doesn't have uh
doesn't allow cannabis or cannabis
infused product sales at all
shouldn't allow them to sell those
products to
to atc patients
um that's my opinion so i don't know
what the number is for the atcs to say
how many patients do we need to remain
viable we know that if this program gets
a significant number of patients will
stop going to the atcs stop going to
their doctors stop going to get the
education and um and they're going to go
to the cheaper market i don't know what
that number of patients is you know that
that makes these atc's non-viable
um
we we just don't know um matt didn't say
the number we don't we don't know what
the number is um but these are these are
point these are small points to uh
increase the possibility that that
remains viable if you're not going to
allow edibles and other cannabis infused
products for the general population
you shouldn't allow the state stores to
sell it to the medical population
okay um
so so here's the
so this this gets really
sticky
i mean so first they're
not for profit the atcs
uh if we say okay
okay there's two two levels of this one
is
okay
you can you can grow
do you think they would want to grow
and manufacture
for the state stores
the atcs
you were you heard you heard one of the
atc's saying that they that they would i
believe that it's a possibility if they
did it's a way to remain viable i'd be
concerned that they're like there's way
more money over there
um in a general in a general you know a
more standard uh recreational market
there's way more more money in um in rec
than there is in medical and they would
just go over there but i don't see a
whole lot of money the problem yeah then
the problem becomes in the license part
i mean the retail part
how do we pull that off we're saying we
haven't no it's a liquor store we're
having a
our retail stores are
under the the auspices of our liquor
commission
how do we how do we
do we license some have a special
license
for the atcs to to sell
on a recreation side like we had talked
about in the commission
i i don't know i mean the bill's got to
say something right
you know um and i don't know what it is
to say yet you know to allow to make
that that uh that dual stream work under
this model um and i don't know if we're
going to figure it out in the next you
know we already have for the next you
know the next couple weeks probably
wrote this out by wednesday or something
so
i don't know you know i would raise
one more concern about the what the bill
says right now and that is that
if the state stores are to sell to
medical patients
meaning somebody shows a card
that means that the state stores need to
sell cannabis that complies with current
state regulations related to
uh medical marijuana or therapeutic
cannabis um so what that means that's
under the under with no changes this
sets up a dual regulatory structure for
cannabis sold in the stores it's unclear
to me whether or not a patient shows up
from massachusetts shows their mass card
and only wants to buy flour
that they have to buy medical flour or
can they buy recreational flour but at
the very least if they're going to buy
an edible or cannabis infused product
that cannabis infused product from the
cultivation from manufacturing
needs to comply with our standards the
therapeutic cannabis program standards
it's a duplication of effort duplication
of regulatory structure um it's
it's problematic unless we unless we
tease it out so the solution to that is
not allow the uh the state stores to
sell
medical uh to medical patients
the last thing i would say is that uh
the um the the issue with the the
set-aside the 25 million dollar
set-aside for hhs um it needs to be
iron-clad that it's not diverted to
other purposes like we see with the
liquor liquor money
alcohol fund
the language needs to be stronger to
ensure that that money comes to hhs for
spending the proper way
okay tim
so if i can kind of summarize kind of
what you said so i understand
you're in favor of removing the medical
from the state like a store component
from the state the cannabis stores all
together does that sound like
department is neutral on the bill uh
this is the first time the department
has ever not been opposed to a cannabis
legalization bill um and
i would
the only workable model under this would
be to remove in my mind would be to
remove
cannabis infused product sales
from the medicine from the state store
follow-up
and the second aspect relative to
allowing the parallel licensor of
existing atcs to be able to sell
to the state
that
has
well right i'm sorry cultivators
manufacturers and transporters that that
currently licensed under
the therapeutic cannabis
licensure to allow parallel licensure of
those states we'd have to look into the
medical statutes to make sure there's no
conflicting language over there
i think allowing them to enter this
market
increases the chances of their viability
and so we would need to explore
the ability for them to
thank you for that market
okay um
okay we have
let's say we're like oh we have until
next wednesday let's say
let's assume we're going to vote it out
on it so we have some work to do
to amend us i'm looking at you tim
okay
to see what we can
do and i think this is a larger
discussion for the full committee on
friday as well
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you
so
uh i would like to say that um all the
conversations that we're having in here
right now are conversations that have
been going on for the past several days
independently of us talking to other
legislators and us talking to
organizations outside of the legislature
uh to to find a pathway for
uh to stop arrest in the state and um i
think that what i'm hearing today is
that there's there's a reluctance to let
the state do it but in the same tense if
the state's
going to do it and this is a bill that
can make it through then let's let's
open a market for the atcs
to cultivate for the state and
make this a forward-thinking bill
i know that everybody talks about
privatization in the future you know
right now this is not exactly
privatization this is the state the
state controlling the sale which i have
no i don't care who sells it as long as
it becomes legal you know i i'm tired of
seeing people's lives ruined
for for a mistake that they made in
public and people are using cannabis
anyway
they're using it anyway
so um let's let's try to be forward
thinking with the bill
the last set of conversations here was
we don't want to harm our atc's so
that's
okay
i just want to move on to the next item
number six
um page eight line 23-36 which
basically talks about um
and page nine lines one through 20
apparently
so this is talking about the revenue
what we do with revenue not necessarily
how much revenue we get but strictly
what we do with it
and i have a couple recommendations for
changes changing that to make it a
little cleaner because i have to tell
you i went to chairman abbas i think
three or four times trying to understand
how we're spending the money
because the language that was in the
bill was confusion had confusion to me
so i have a couple an idea i'd like to
float by the the members that have
conversation points around it
um
so
one of the first things the bill does is
the first spend we do is to pay back
the taxpayer for the upfront cost of
opening the businesses
there's 14 million dollars in the fiscal
note that estimating on 10 stores
i'm pretty sure the liquor commission is
not going to try to open 10 stores all
at once
and that the reality is this is going to
be a rolling effort um over probably two
years um for them to be able to get
there
and so what my initial thought was again
i still want to pay the taxpayer back
for the cost based on the
the lack of better phrase the profits
that come from the sale of cannabis
um and and however i think that the 14
million is probably a little aggressive
i know fiscal has a problem with that
number
um i'd like to cut that by to a third of
that number but make it a revolving fund
so as funds come into the cannabis fund
they can reinvest them back to open the
next store and then as more money comes
in they can reinvest over the next door
so rather than try to come up with 14
million dollars at once we come up with
one third of that which is whatever it
is four point something three point
something
um
and and roll that into a rolling fund so
ultimately they can open up all their
stores
um i keep i'd like to keep the second
provision which is
after after the uh
the
um
paying back the general public for the
loan
interest-free loan um that we pay the
operational costs
and then you end up with a net number
that's left after your startup costs
after your operational cost you end up
with a net number that's left over which
is actually what we can use to help the
citizens in new hampshire for
for um tax relief and other things
so what i'd like to suggest is that we
put 50 of that net
towards this statewide education
property tax
um and to help reduce that cost
on the off chance that 50 percent of
that net revenue equals the entire swept
which is three point uh 363 million
dollars i think uh which means we'd have
to make
um
whatever
whatever that number is over six hundred
thousand million dollars in net revenue
um
that any overage that should occur would
go to the new hampshire retirement
system debt
because that's going to directly help
our
our taxpayers and then if the new
hampshire retirement debt is paid off
then it would go to the
education trust fund so 50
if we don't reach the swept then it's
irrelevant but if we do reach the full
swept amount
then the overage first would go to the
new hampshire retirement system if that
debt is paid off then it would go to the
education trust fund the next stack of
number is 30 to the new hampshire
retirement system debt
as we all know
that this is a huge cost to our citizens
um the the amount that towns have to pay
for their for this debt that's you know
i think we have a 25 years left on the
buyout if we can accelerate that that's
only going to help our towns and cities
it'll help our employees because once
that debt's paid off we can reduce the
amount of percentage they have to pay
towards retirement which ends up into a
pay raise for them basically
um so i'd like to see 30 of that go to
the new hampshire retirement system to
pay off the debt and again once the
debts paid off the balance would go to
the education trust fund
the next would be 10 to the department
of health and human services for
cessation programs or 25 million dollars
whichever is less
and again i think at some point we reach
a max threshold how many citizens i do
have some information i'll forward to
the rest of the committee i got from
uh the department on cessation programs
and funding sources and the amount of
money their expenditure they're
expending at dhhs but again i think we
do 10 of the
of the net revenues
or 25 million dollars which gives the
fund lots of money to be able to help
any citizens that are coming for
cessation programs
the last 10 is broken up in two buckets
that are already identified in the
statute five percent would go to police
for training and services uh for
training services and then
um five percent would go to the
children's mental health program to at
dhhs to help help kids
so that's what i'm proposing as a
general this conversation starting point
to
amend that all of that language that's
talking about how we spend the net
revenues and amend it to that again 50
to swept 30 percent of new hampshire
retirement system
10 or 25 million whichever is less to
dhhs for cessation programs
um five percent to the children's
behavioral and five percent to the um
police and if i did my math right that
equals 100
well my first point is that uh this is
exactly the kind of proposal that we've
got three members of the finance
committee sitting on our
larger committee to uh help us think
about and
i'd look to
them for guidance uh i guess as a
general matter i i would want not want
to see
that that level of detail
in a statute
that's going forward that's the kind of
thing that should be sorted out
by
the legislature and with the help of its
finance committee
as part of the budget process i think
but
there can be room for priorities and
certainly in the context of this bill it
makes sense that there be
uh the kind of priority that's expressed
in the bill right now
in terms of putting 25 million dollars
into
programs that
substance use disorder treatment of it
and so forth
and
i guess that's what i want to say i i'd
be very
very very careful about
being too specific and too
long in
in
sort of predicting what the needs will
be
four years six years out
which is what you'd be doing by
cementing it in statute
i'd favor putting
the excess money for example into the
education trust fund period
and if that
means that over time you can have a
reduction in the uh
swept
so be it but
because the education trust fund has
been filled up by these other revenues
but i i wouldn't uh
up front
make that
that decision regarding a particular tax
there are other taxes we could consider
as well
so that's that's my initial take on that
kind of that kind of proposal and i
really look forward
we have to have the finance
committee members input on that
so
my take on this is
first off i i really think you got to
confer we have three days of session
the three members of finance that are
been attached to this committee they all
couldn't make it because they're in
other hearings right now
um that that you confer with them
because they have their ideas
okay so but i think you got to convince
them if you convince them
that that that go for it
um
the thing though is
before you really come with these break
points
that
hopefully we get to it today we gotta we
gotta we gotta start the discussion on
how much revenue we really think we're
going to get from this
because you know the 25 million may eat
up the whole thing
you know what i mean
whatever you may eat up the whole thing
so it may be a smaller pot that's going
to be divided up so we've you know what
i mean i agree that's why i did it
i don't want to have more discussion on
this today because it's really i agree
with the finance
that in terms because i know during the
hearing uh i saw heard from some of
these guys that said you know
they view this as an appropriation
forever
and they want to change they want to
chime chime in and i think
if you could take the lead on that talk
with them i have had a couple
conversations but i'll continue to have
some more okay thank you
so let's keep on going
um
i think we're getting the other banking
one
um so if i can mr chair the next the
next number seven
my recommendation is that we just strike
all the banking language right out i
think it was clear from the banking
industry itself new hampshire bankers
association said that these
programs are available to atc's into
cannabis related companies to be able to
do their financial needs
and then we heard from the banking
commission that as the bill's written i
think that we were 59 million dollars
short in our appropriation of 10 million
dollars and then it would require an
ongoing infusion of cash from the state
as deposits increased for the state bank
if it was ever to be created so i think
that we should just strike all the
banking language okay uh i want to have
ryan come up a second uh he he i think
he agrees with you
and i think we all agree
on that one
uh but there's one one thing he'd i
think he'd like to see done so
oh i'm sorry okay
and the president of the bank mr
chairman you asked for one you get two
that's how this works
yes why don't you both uh introduce
yourselves and then sure christy merrill
president new hampshire bankers
association
and ryan hale vice president uh
government relations for new hampshire
yes thank you for your comments
representative lang
we did want to just raise that in the
event
yes sorry um
in the event the state banking language
does come out which we have asked for we
do believe there may be some additional
language that might be helpful for
bankers just to give them some
additional protection that
that would just help them to get into
the space as well so we don't have that
for you today
but if that's something the group is
agreeable to we'd be happy to help
provide that
um
yeah we'd like to see that
you can just send it to me and all that
i'll look at it if i need it like right
away but if you can get me that language
right away um then i'll try to introdu
i'll try to in my amendment incorporate
uh some protections for the bankers that
enter into this
market
thank you thank you very much
mr chairman
i do know that um
that
we appreciate
the banking association coming forward
and saying we think we can help you out
here
uh it was it was there was a lot of
discussion previously on whether or not
that could happen
uh thank you for stepping up and saying
we have we have members who may be able
to help
thank you thank you can i ask you a
question you know and just a naive
question about banking i'm not a banker
but
if um
obviously marijuana cannabis is illegal
federally
and if all the small bank you have
stated that the number of banks stepped
up and said they could help us you know
as an alternative banking you know um
source
how does that work um that a small bank
that say it's a small bank right in the
middle of the state has no interstate
commerce but still has fdic insurance
for their customers
how does a small bank be able to do that
in the face of a federal you know law
against cannabis
yeah that's a complicated question but
um i would answer that by saying fincen
has issued guidance um and as part of
that guidance they they explain how
banks can get into this space
you know as we've talked about before
there are a lot of banks around the
country and credit unions in the space
and so they they try to follow the
guidance and by that guidance it's
really laid a path for them to do so and
it has to do with um
filing the with sars which i'm i'm
blanking on what that stands for
suspicious activity report thank you
um so it it has it determines it's based
on the type of relationship and if it's
a direct banking relationship and the
level of suspicious activity reports
they have to file and things like that
so we believe that that helps
create a pathway for banks my only
reference point was that in a hospital
if you do not if you take in medicare
patients medicaid patients you are
obliged to follow all the federal
regulations
but it doesn't it appears that you can
get around that in the banking industry
is that correct
yes it's it's still illegal federally as
you said so that's a problem um and we
believe it needs to be addressed at the
federal level you know we've i've
mentioned this at the hearing but
we've been advocating very strongly for
years for the safe banking act which
would give bankers protection um from
from regulators when they are
banking cannabis in states where it's
thank you mr chairman um going off of
that uh do you have any types of
reporting or anything that has come out
about uh problems that banking has in uh
gone through when they've moved into the
space that maybe you could share with us
are there don't have anything top of
mind but i can certainly try to find
some
thank you
and representative murphy um
during the hearing i believe we handed
out the vincent guidance i do have a
copy if you'd like an extra copy of it
okay i think we're all set in the
banking thing you'll work with
the representative lang thank you that'd
be great we got about a half hour left i
do want to get to revenues i'm going to
uh um mr chair number on number um
eight i do have an edit on page 11 line
i would strike where they say additional
investigators and change it to market
consultants it's just a typo that was a
cut and paste kind of problem right so
and that should take care of that right
they were asking for that delicate
commission thank you so what's your word
market consultants
they have no expertise there in in
cannabis at all they need somebody that
understands how this all works
and we should give them that
okay
uh the number um
is everyone okay with that okay
so
um
that was that was next round page 12 up
around line
seven and we're looking at this is where
we talked about talking about we've
already talked about eleven so keep on
going
then
well yeah eleven was coming up with no
we have ten first right so we skipped
over ten ten is talking about the limits
the cultivators and retail stores are
unbounded and whether or not we want to
change anything and mr chair i just say
that i kind of looked us like we did at
the sports betting bill well i don't
like a limit on cultivators and i'd
rather remove it it's all going to be
based on roi and return on investment
and the industry will decide how much is
needed
as you said currently there are only
three atc's and if we allow them the
right to cultivate manufacture and
transport we're still going to need more
cultivators manufacturers and
transporters beyond that
as they may not be able to meet the
state need or decide to go in i think
this probably is a reasonable limit
i'd rather
take it out myself but
but i'm also willing to treat it like we
did our
our sports betting where we limited the
number of sports betting book locations
retail locations on the initial outset
of the bill to see how it was handled
and then we can make adjustments going
forward all right
because my big question was
is if we don't know how many stores
they're going to be and then but we're
not limiting the number of stores
but we're limiting the number of of
cultivators
right i think i think i think that we
need to be uh wary of the fact that if
the market grows then
as the stores are implemented
more product is going to be needed
and
fortunately the atc's are already set up
to grow or have the availability to
duplicate their process if they in fact
know that they're going to have
um a market to sell it to
um and they're and they're allowed so
that that number i don't i don't know
why the number's in there not all
cultivation like you know
it goes for the stores are we big stores
small stores they could be big big
they even put a bound on it doesn't make
sense whatever the market the market's
going to dictate eventually
what it is
yeah
is there any reason for this number that
uh
those involved in drafting this
yeah no my understanding was probably
just
we're going to hear from the chair oh
yep
thank you again
i won't name any names but
i think we all know the name but that's
okay but the number 15 was not set in
stone so if people are concerned that
that number is too low
i mean if you were going to increase
that i would just
think conservatively on what you want to
do but
maybe 20 would be a good number
i think problem is we're throwing a dart
right we're guessing right and no matter
what number we guess we're going to be
way too high or way too low again i go
back to sportsbet and we we allocated
for 10 retail locations we have four in
the state and it's been over two years
since we legalized sports
retail sports betting so i think this is
a number we can dynamically adapt as
someone can introduce a bill to increase
if we're at 100 capacity and we can just
adjust the number or remove it all
together if that's what we want to do i
think it's a good starting point just to
respond to that i think the uh
the risk is the it does prove to be a
set an artificial constraint on
on the
supply
of this product that's needed
for sale and if it turns out that there
are a whole bunch of cultivators that
want to get in
and that's how
how it's going in new hampshire
we'll have a number in the statute
that's hard to change
uh so uh but if uh it has to be there
because it's it's quote the policy
that's come to us so be it uh you know
i'm not gonna fight that but uh it does
seem kind of kind of crazy when we don't
really have any
uh understanding of why
other than arbitrary stuff and uh sports
betting places are really expensive to
set up so there was some reason to you
know limit that number
i understood again i i don't like the
arbitrary number but if it's something
we need to compromise get it through
let's you know we're not going to have
stores up until after july of 23 we have
plenty of time to introduce new bills if
we want to change that number yeah i
don't know i agree let's let's not throw
the dart again
one dart's enough so we'll keep it at
the 10 for now
and uh
15 sorry 15.
so on to the next is
is where we were talking about working
with finance to come up with the number
that they're willing to fund
and that number is going to dictate how
fast we are able to open the stores
if they don't if they don't want to give
us 14 million up front
they don't want to appropriate 14
million for next because this is
the problem they got is we said it was
i think the surplus of about 300 million
and they got well over that already in
requests so
they
you know
it's
and they they they
we've already been told they want a
lower number than the 14 million
so all that would do is just throw the
implementation in terms of the number of
stores that we can open and there's
probably
um there's only certain amount of stores
we can open at one time anyway so that
make that opening may
happen over a couple of years anyway so
so they'll be looking for an appropriate
well and this tim with tim's idea was
that well we get the first group of
stores open they're generally running
revenue
all this other spending to or
to other
organizations or whatever to offset
whatever we want to offset it keeps on
getting plowed back into opening new
stores
until
using using the actual let's say we open
three or four stores initially
those stores start generating revenue
they make to make a profit in that
that that money would be plowed back
into opening the next set of stores i
think that's your idea tim right okay so
that's that's what we're talking about
so
and but but we have to get a number out
of an official official number out of
fiscal how much they're willing to
appropriate
is
is and i'm getting the vibes from
finance that they're not gonna they're
not gonna bite on the 14 million for the
first year
so my question was the liquor commission
seemed to be not amenable really to have
them physically within their current
liquor store is that correct oh that's
never going to happen right so if that's
the case these are all stand-alone
freestanding new buildings which would
be substantially more to cost correct oh
yeah or storefronts right with the
existing
yeah they do that in some of the smaller
it's not going to be yeah it's probably
going to be slow so that they have the
gut and this right okay
so mr chair i'll work with i'll work
with um
finance when i'm talking about the other
issue um and we'll look at those two
ideas of like i said the role the
plowing the money back into the grow the
stores i think at some point they're
going to want to cap on that
so we're not doing it for the next 15
years and opening up 30 stores and
nobody ever gets any money beyond that
but we can i'll talk to them about
putting again my idea was one-third it
allows them to open three or four stores
depending on their their model um and
then use those three or four stores as a
funding source to open up future stores
okay that's fine do whatever you can
work out with them
and then
then my number 12 was just that there
was also an appropriation of a hundred
and fifty thousand
for hhs it just just walked out of the
they were here a second ago
oh
no this is for uh hhs to
for preliminary media campaign to
be approved for uh for for a media
campaign
that was before the stores opened up
it's in the bill for 150 000
and that would be i don't know if that
would be your area of hhs abigail was
okay all i'm gonna say here is that
pretend when you talk to them about the
appropriation
i will i'll find out about the 150. okay
oh
yes
that that was in conversation that that
150 was put in as part of the amendment
the initial request or recommendation
was 250 trying to keep the
fiscal note as low as possible
was put at 150 but if that number is
insufficient to do anything
significant perhaps it needs to be
reconsidered
my point was that
you know in addition to the 14 million
requests there was 150 000 i mean
it's not a big number
um
but when we're talking to finance about
it we might as well just wrap all that
discussion both of those into one
discussion so
um
okay now we're getting to the big
uh
those they
were revised
they revised uh fiscal notes
oh here it is it's on the top of the
pile yeah
okay
so
we're all just seeing this so bear with
us here
um
so we have a whole slew of
agencies that
collaborated we have the liquor
commission the judicial branch
judicial council new hampshire
association of counties
new hampshire
municipal association new hampshire
business finance authority
and the department of justice and
department of justice safety etc
and banking so
i think some of these will fall off
because
um
you know we're going to remove the
banking yeah the first section was
banking
so i don't think we even have bothered
with those because we are we're not
going to be dealing with that i think
that's coming off the top so we're on to
the bill appropriates 14 uh for uh 14
million
uh
10 stores this is very similar to their
original
you
know just want to see where they came up
with this if there's any
uh there's any revenue projections it's
just costing projections in here and
that that hasn't changed really from the
original
so there's no change in that
i'm on the show i'm on the chart here uh
uh
again this is not much more new
information than the original fiscal
note
where they estimated how much it would
but i've not seen anything about revenue
yeah no right i i haven't thumb through
it
uh
they don't talk about revenues anyway
well that doesn't help us
yes all right well
they're their
original their original note to us
and she's okay it was
the person who dismembered the sheet
that was hanging out
so i spoke to her this morning is the
the
fiscal officer from the liquor
commission she's going to join us on
friday
she'll be with
the person who did this original note is
going to join us on friday she'll walk
us through how she did this
okay she couldn't come today
so
um
but if i took her
she did it on a
average
net
basically average net profit
and but but that includes edibles by the
way in it right she started with an
average per capita cost of 35.54 cents
per person
based on our um based on all the other
per capitas they they estimated coming
out with a total sales revenue of
two point four five point two million
dollars in sales which nets out to
uh forty nine million forty three
thousand fourteen dollars in net revenue
to the state
um from that we would have to take our
operational expenses um and the payback
um
and we know that and mr chair i guess if
i look at your again going back to your
your flow conversation here
talking about flow hubs numbers um we'd
be looking at about assuming all that
those numbers are right but we take out
edibles and we take out cartridges
um our net are we're looking at a 56
percent
number um so it would because edibles
are 18 cartridges are 26 44 of sales so
we're looking at cutting our sales
basically by 44
by limiting those factors
and so we're still looking at a again as
i said 56 which is over 25 million
dollars in revenue
to the state
which is
and i i don't know what i did with my
huh
uh
i from the from the study that we did
from the the marijuana commission study
that we did the commission that we had
our midpoint was around 50 million
that included edibles
full bore
that the
revenue to the state
and the range was seven percent retail
tax to 15
so it rains but if you took the midpoint
of that
it wasn't i i can't well
i did it just by percentages we looked
at again using this flow saying is that
the the liquor commission
came up with a similar number yeah to 50
million so again we're looking at 25
million dollars roughly a little more in
revenue to the state
that we would use to
pay for the program and to offset help
our citizens that's mr chairman is there
is there any reference to our
surrounding states and their net
revenues
they're different models but i mean
did do we have any breakdown for that or
well then the the third the third
i'll get to the answer that but then
there's a third um
dick dick said i can't find anything
here
yeah it was the one on the prior bill
last year's bill there was a there was a
fiscal note
i think the biggest problem is that that
contemplated a full-blown privatization
retail right market which isn't what
we're doing so it's a little bit apple
orange conversation actually that that
that fiscal note was a lot lower now why
don't why can't i find it here in this
pile of stuff
um
from the one that you gave me this
morning
i thought we handed that out but maybe
not
no it's lower this is
we're both having problems here with all
it was a bill
that was retained last year
that was full commercialization
legalization of full commercialization
and we had the represent me
representative alame sent to all of us
the
237. i have it here
so mr chair are you looking at the 481
um fiscal note which had
so it's the 481 the one that it's a
quick fiscal note on 481 that's not it
that's still this is this is 230 yeah
this is house bill 237.
well this is this is from your i believe
this is the one that had the study
committee that ultimate this was the
fiscal note that was assigned to it and
assumptions no this isn't from that
it's
this is for 41 yes this is 41.
and
the range
was
19. we'll call it 20 million to 31
million
but all i'm going to say on this
this
this methodology looked awfully familiar
and it's and it does say it is the same
methodology we used
in the in the
marijuana commission report it's the new
york city new york state methodology
that they use because
and this was done by department of
revenue and they just took that and they
put more new numbers in it
so because it had tourism factoring a
lot that was
you know
and it's based on the number of ounces
per person per year
and uh
and then times
uh
an estimate of the number of users
this was like 131
people who would consume this
which is kind of consistent with
with
you know if we did a percentage on the
population that i mentioned earlier
that's that's about 15 of the population
would would be using
go to any any retail store
so
and
and it doesn't say here what they use
for a rate but
uh
what
oh i see what they did they calculated
and then they used something a rate a
tax rate
every ounce should be taxed at 30 an
ounce
was there
that it looks like it would be taxed at
the wholesale level the grower level
and that that's how they did it
so this is very low
19 to 20 million to 31 million
but that's what was yeah it would be
okay if i asked uh mr simon a question
uh i don't know matt because of your
prime now if you can talk to past
history or not but do you do you uh
understand the percentages of sales that
were done on the
um other than flower market
from from surrounding states
so we would kind of like look at look at
that'd be helpful that would be very
what what is non-flower usage as opposed
to flower usage
thank you very much if you can we would
yeah um
representatives
where did you get your
numbers from
and what are they
thank you again
what i did is i looked at the fiscal
note for hb 237
which is similar to hp 481 the
difference is if rather than just have a
thirty dollar tax the wholesale level it
was a five percent transfer tax and a
nine percent sales tax
but i looked at the gross sales
into hb 237 on the high end was 340
million with considering the legal
market that's just the gross sales the
lower end was uh i don't have the fiscal
number frontier but it's about 150
million on there was a lower end
as well
that would
it was about a 200 000 difference so
what i did was i looked at the gross
sales and i kind of at first i was
considering what is the markup from the
wholesale level to retail
and from what i understood with the
flower and i've
had this conversation with several
different individuals in the industry it
does vary
uh some say 80 some say 90 some say 120
it really depends on how much they're
selling what the strain is there's a lot
of things to take into consideration so
i kind of just used the 80 markup as
opposed to
uh a tax of which i considered 14 so
that's kind of where my numbers came
from
another analysis way of looking at it
would be if you charge what is the
profit margin at the retail sale
in my understanding that the general
goal is around 50
as a profit margin
again if you're selling in large volumes
that it's nothing wrong with that being
around 40 percent it really depends on
the volume
so if the gross but what i what stuck
out to me was
it also had the illegal market sales and
on the high end was 311 million dollars
so
whether you have a private retail model
or
what what hp 1598 proposes
there's a significant market share just
being lost now
in those gross sales figures there's
nothing distinguishing between
manufactured products and flour
so
i couldn't decipher how exact i would
just say if it's about a 30 market share
you would have to reduce the gross sales
by 30 would be in this again we're
ballparking it
was your gross sale
just marijuana or did it include the
edibles
well the different models i know what
for 237
it would have allowed full recreation
use of edible products or manufactured
products so the number i used in
converting that
when i talked about the markup i stayed
with just the flower which has the
lowest markup trying to keep the numbers
as conservative as possible
the markup on the manufactured products
from what i understand is much higher
but the 340 million
was that just the flower
no that that because that came that
would include edible sales everything
yes that's a gross number right that's
the that's the sales yes that's just the
gross commercial what was your what was
your net after all it's said and done
what was your net
if
with the profit if
because we're trying to find out what
the product is in this model it's about
the profits that are going to be made by
the uh cannabis
uh stores that are going to be
transferred to the state
as profits so we're trying that's what
we're really trying to get at
so if the markup on the flower is
let's just say 80
if you look at the gross sales
and you instead of looking at it from a
tax perspective you look at the market
perspective
i was coming my numbers are coming in at
is this is now gross revenue share of
around 250 million dollars
but that's also not taken in taking into
consideration the out-of-state consumer
for liquor
for any given year we're between 40 and
where hb 237 was right around two
percent
so
that i'm not factoring the odyssey
market
being i was kind of thinking
ballpark that would be around 20 to 30
percent i don't think that's unrealistic
considering
especially in southern new hampshire a
lot of the market and economy there is
fueled by
out-of-state consumers okay so back up
so forget about the out-of-state for a
minute so okay so we have the so you're
saying that gross is what gross is three
something or is it the 250
i think the gross revenue
would be around 250 million dollars not
taken into consideration the out of
state consumer okay i'm talking about
purely retail sales so that 250 then
you're saying
you're saying from that 250 gross a
profit will be x and then that will
leave us with a net right
if you if you back out what you think
the profit's going to be or
what the costs are of
of
the other problem we have
we're trying to get what the profit's
the gross sales 340 million that
included the edibles
correct
and
if you took the edibles out
million
yes
and now you can use your 80 on that
right
yes you could and and so that your high
would be 80 of 170 million which would
be
i trust the math is correct i didn't
break it down but all right so we're
rather than operating from the 340.
right
okay but i have trouble saying that uh
are we saying that
that the profits are
on marijuana stores are 80 margins
no i what i was saying that that is the
market from retail to wholesale i mean
sorry from wholesale to retail
going back that's where my my numbers
initially came from
but i i think
if you focus on what the profit margin
is
and
one of the reasons why i would hope that
at some point we allow
full manufacturing product let's do it
this way so we don't can we just to make
sure
between now and friday is there any way
you could just kind of sketch that out
for us
let's say we started here we went then
we did this and then we did that it'd be
very helpful
to know i can make a flowchart uh
showing the math yeah that would be
going to be helpful
again i did
i still think
ignoring the potential out of state
market would be
you could do a chart with it and without
it
you know what i mean in one of the
rationales if you notice the quantity
limit one can purchase is higher than
hp 237 and hb
41. and the reason why
it was drawn or written that way was to
factor in out-of-state sales as well
did you say hp 41
hb 41
when it was as amended by the ways and
means committee last term in hb 237 they
went to criminal justice and public
safety committee this term are almost
identical
but you see we're trying to get out here
you know we're trying to understand what
we think
we think that's going to be
um
so any other
questions on that okay
thank you
um
and again we're gonna have okay so we're
kind of running out of time here today
um
i think we got some actions that we uh
jim i think you've got some you got the
list can i run through them real quick
yeah all right so you know um
uh where do i start so we're gonna fix
the regulation licensure and
registration in the admin in the admin
rules
look at what language changes are needed
to allow the atcs to sell to the state
we're gonna look at the revenue split
and talk to finance about that and see
if the split that i i talked up works
for them
we're going to talk to finance and see
what the dollar amount is to the state
to do us the startup costs and what
their what finances can find palatable
and how to make that work
i'm going to change that language about
market consultant from investigators
we're going to strike the banking
language and i think that was pretty
much
everything we had
um
within reason
we decided to leave the number of
cultivators change that number and ask
finance about 150 000 to dhhs
um but the big question is
allowing the atcs to sell to the state
and the break the makeup of the model
how do we adjust that and adopt that
i'll reach out to someone over at dhhs
and see if i can get an answer
and then again
if the revenue is only 50 million we
still haven't agreed on a number yet
it's only 50 million
that cascading of
how the revenue gets spent
maybe altered don't you think
well it's one of the reasons why for
dhhs i put a percentage and now i put a
percentage not to exceed a dollar amount
was because as the industry grows the
revenue to dhhs will grow to deal with
the possible increase in demand
and so you know by doing a fixed number
of 25 million
was problematic because again if
depending what that number is that we
have come in that could eat up 100 of
all the revenues and nobody gets
anything else we still got other
problems to solve
or potential problems itself
okay i want to ask representative major
okay can we just pull out calendars here
a second to see
um
do you think we're going to exact this
on next wednesday
i'll tell you why because
we have to have it on that whatever it's
next wednesday by noon right in order to
make the calendar for the following week
which is crossover
so wednesday at noon we have we'd have
to have it exact by so we can get it
over to the clerk
so mr chair how do we want to how do we
want to handle this because
we we
can we're gonna have a work session on
this
um hopefully you know we'll bring all of
right
that that'll be good can we also
schedule one for tuesday in case we need
it
and then say exactly we may not need it
or
is that a subcommittee or do we want to
do we want to do can we do a
subcommittee on on monday and then have
a
i have a tuesday work session and a
friday final vote
i i'm just anticipating there's going to
be a lot more discussion needed i don't
want to show this by not having enough
time the 18th we're meeting right
we have a ways and means session on the
18th yes so how about following that we
have a sub-committee meeting
we have to get on the calendar yes
we'll meet the 24-hour notice that we
submit on wednesday
so
i don't i'm available
friday after after we get done with all
our other business
we are going to hear some testimony from
we were saying is just the subcommittee
to meet
um
in the afternoon
and then then have a work session on on
friday on
the following monday again i think he's
having he's thinking about having the
whole committee work session following
noon we could discuss the amendment and
then the
subcommittee can come back okay all
right
okay
right okay
all right so
um
any other comments
questions other questions from the
audience
or concerns i'm looking at my friend
over here
we're not the community to hear your
concerns you know um
so
i think we're all set then 12 30 i know
the democrats have a
have a uh
a caucus they got to go thank you all
we'll see everybody on friday and we'll
you